Now that we've built the model,
let us validate
by applying the model to the validation
set and observing the accuracy.
In Alteryx we'll use the model
comparison tool as we did for
all the other models up to this point.
So we already have this model built out.
So what we should do is bring
in that model comparison tool.
The model object from the boosted model
goes in to this model comparison tool
M input, and
the validation data set goes into the D
input for the model comparison tool.
I'm then going to bring in a browse
tool after this R output, and
run this comparison.
So let's open up these results now.
The first thing,
like we saw with all the other models,
I'm going to look at the accuracy.
And it looks like this boosted model
predicting the mode of transportation
for employees was 83% accurate
in predicting the validation or
the independent dataset.
What I also see is that it was very good
at predicting the car individuals, but
not very good at predicting
the people who rode their bikes or
took public transportation to work.
Now we can see the breakdown and not the
percentages, but the actual values of
where our things were misclassified
over in the confusion matrix.
It seems to me that people who
were incorrectly predicted
fell typically in the car bucket.
This typically happens when we have one
category that is much more dominant than
other categories.
But overall, looking at this
model comparison reports,
it seems like we have again a pretty
strong model, it has an overall accuracy
of 0.8315, with very strong accuracy
measures in predicting the car.
While on the other side, predicting if
employees take public transportation or
ride their bike to work was
actually a real challenge.
So very similar results that we've seen
before in the previous two models.
This is overall definitely
a strong model, but
I'd like to do some
comparisons side by side
against the other models to determine
which one we should use in production.